there's a lot of people out there that
think they know the mob so you've killed
all these guys I mean it's not a short
list of people it's easy for me to hurt
somebody will kill something that's the
easy part
did someone say did you kill Johnny
Gavin who's got a row Paul G Nicky
Pasquale Penney Nicole yes I did I was
loyal to the mom they betrayed you can't
trust somebody you don't say it to shut
these people that don't know what
they're talking about John you're saying
you were bigger than the Gotti senior
and junior he doesn't belong in this
life there is no honor
it's treachery there is no love it's
only about money it's only about an
individual surviving happened the police
just stumbled on us they were coming in
the direction of shooting and I start
huffing on my feet and I leave the cause
of a cop's gang called by my grave cross
Atlantic Avenue I start jumping fence in
some backyards and I've taken a gun
apart and drop it in and so it has are
mine do you still miss any of it anybody
says they don't miss the life there's a
lawyer
[Music]
so today I have John a light with me as
a guest John a light was part of the
Gambino family as an associate who was
working directly with John Gotti Jr
there were good friends from early on
teenagers and he's been known as one of
the main hitmen of the Gambino family if
not the main Hitman and so today's
conversation is going to be more than
mafia series having said that piers
johnny-light John thanks for coming out
thank you for having me so so you know
one of the questions before we get into
everything that we got how did you even
get into having a relationship with John
Gotti Jr how did that connection
connection take place with the two of
you I grew up back in Woodhaven Queens
you may give and you I grew up around
them all so before Gotti senior juniors
father took over the mob and I re as the
boss and the fatty and earu Gianna was
the boss who I was close with the family
with the sons they play baseball wooden
legs the box at the same gym and he was
the captain Gambino family that ran our
area when he went to prison
senior took over and stepped in his
shoes and that's what you start
reporting to is whoever takes over that
position so the introduction was made
through the community that you kind of
meet him were you guys friends at what
age did you meet John Gotti Jr well jr.
and me were became we knew each other
when jr. was about 16 years old I was a
year older than him at 17 we were
introduced through mutual friends said
alone goodbye and he would come up to
Jamaica every once in a while seen a guy
named Johnny Cabot actually he's one of
the guys I ordered his murder the first
week I wanted to prison I told him to
hit this guy when I go to prison so that
was his introduction to me and him and
later on that ended up being a
yes me and jr. had that love-hate
relationship since with children Oh
since since him 16 years 17 so right off
the bat you guys had a love-hate
relationship yeah there was a on his end
he needed us guys from Jamaica Avenue
because he wanted to become he had
aspirations to be like his father so he
wanted to meet some tough guys and
Jamaica and he was where we grew up well
guys that didn't have money we come from
a a poverty-stricken area where he grew
up was a rich area so in order for him
to feel that he was being getting his
feet wet in the street he had to come up
did you make a band you and me me and
some of my friends so his initial friend
was Joey Cabot who was a street guy yeah
I mean us so at that 8:17 was Jeff was
his father already the boss of the
Gambino family has added happened yet no
past Paul Castellanos event hasn't taken
hasn't taken hasn't technically okay so
at this point of where you're at the
community are you in high school at 70
no you've already been out of snow on
that high I'm in high school still and
who are you in high school I went to
school with you who was Johnny like oh I
was a guy that was known to be in the
gyms boxing all the time he lost
battalion Hall was the gym big names at
that time we're at the gym was David
Sears and he fought Spinks he got
knocked out real quick but he was a
great fighter actually Burt young from
Rocky on them and managed him Gerry
Cooney I did some shows with Gerry
Cooney on his radio show so Gerry Cooney
was in a gym same gym as million Andes
fatty and the original kids
Albert was young great attitude and a
fighter so we all were in those gyms
Billy's dream he ends up getting killed
also so this is like the place this is
the place this is the tough guys place
where you're growing up at oh no doubt
we nicknamed our area death Haven
because most of these guys that were
going to speak about our debt they all
got killed so you know who are the lone
survivors I guess over the years and
there's close to 100 guys that grew us
grew up with us in that neighborhood
that lost their lives now let me out you
said close to hundred guys agree yeah
so growing up as a kid at what age were
you forced to be tough to survive in
that area so right like 5 6 7 how soon
does it start my father was a fanatic
about fighting and not getting bullied
so and
an early age of three years old we were
actually working out doing push-ups and
learning to jump rope four years old
three years old and we had a regimen of
routines in baseball and boxing those
were his do sports for us so we were
known and my father was known in the
area as king of the kids he would bring
kids down and learn how to box with us
and so some of my childhood friends like
Timmy Donahue he's passed away also was
also learned to fight with us my father
brought us in and didn't want us to grow
up in a neighborhood that was tough what
I'll be able to be tough so right off to
bed you're learning how to box they were
right after but now your dad who was
your dad personality-wise once you yang
ster was he connected to anybody was he
just a respected guy was your money guy
was your worker who was your problem my
dad grew up in Rivington and Delancey
Street which is a known hub especially
back when he grew up in the you know in
the 40s and 50s with gangsters like Vito
Genovese were down there and guys like
that famous gangsters in those days so
if he was a hanging around guy he was in
a shooter he was a gambler but he stood
with all gangsters and he was very
friendly but look at Luciano's cousin
Charlie Luciano we used to call Blackie
so I was introduced to him as a young
kid so my father was very familiar with
the world of mob guys what's he trying
to get you to stay away from the world
like what's the link was he kind of like
hey you got to go out there and figure
out a way to make money at all cost what
was the conversation like between you
and your pal
my dad was complete opposite he was a a
gambler a hustler and didn't want me
with the mob world but at the same time
he was bringing me around these guys so
as he's telling me stay away as I'm
getting older I'm getting attracted to
the money and I see my but my father
struggling and I see some of these guys
and they treat me well and you know I'm
getting attracted to that life and I
want I want that life you wanted that
life I wanted that life my father wanted
me to be a pro fighter of a pro
ballplayer you know a baseball player so
he had a different outlook on on things
and he didn't think in my father's mind
I'm very close to my dad is to teach me
to survive that for me to understand the
mob world but to be like him
don't go dive into that word
and I guess he thought that I would
never dive in I'd be like him but it was
the opposite I went to the extreme the
other way you wanted to extreme the
other way mom and dad both Albanian both
humming both Albie okay got it
and so he's trying to you know
encouraging and not to get in but at the
same time you're on the environment you
know gambling you around and at what age
are you're on these folks by the way is
it very like early or very young early
very early very early and are they
taking a liking to you like look you
know we like you you know we like lead
is their name hey little Johnny is John
is were you like somebody that was like
yeah I was a skinny little kid when I
was muscular because I was always doing
push-ups pull-ups and so they used to
joke Johnny walk on your hands because I
could stand on my hands Johnny show us
to do polio and I was like a good dog
doing tricks right I like the attention
that they kept saying it was tough they
showed me to tell me put the hands up it
yeah and I'd hit the hands boxing a
little bit and they'd get a kick out of
me and I got a kick out of them get a
kick out of me so interesting I
continued with a form of entertainment
form of acceptance so at what was the
first experience of making money
illegally or legally for you at what age
again I was in an environment that it
was constant trouble and it was constant
gang-related back in those days you know
back in those days there was a lot of
racial tension because of the times it
was the 60s so I worked in a deli and I
spoke about this cold Dick's deli and it
was a legitimate job and in between
going box and playing baseball I became
the captain of baseball team in high
school I was working in his deli but
that deli introduced me to a couple
things a lot of my friends that were
involved with a gang called 7 and 9 that
were very dangerous and it was basically
it became a huge gang throughout all New
York not just our area and it introduced
me to the corner shop
the car service what happened to me my
girlfriend's father and he was a
gangster with okz family and around the
corner was a bookmaker which was his
brother Luis Gotti and George County and
he ran the local bookmaking area and of
course room how are you at this time
you're saying again maybe 15 when I
started getting involved running slips
for them innocently I
yeah I'm working in Dick's deli and they
asked me do me a favor and run it across
the street so innocently I'm not looking
to get involved to that extent I just
guy's telling me a bookmakers and some
tough guys and a couple kill was that
later on at that age I still don't
realize that killers there will humble
guys and people have the idea the
loudest man in the room is the toughest
and it's complete opposite the guys I've
learned to look up to a guys like
Charlie Luciano that will humble and
quiet a gentleman and those are the guys
when they could turn that switch on and
kill and I try to mimic those guys as I
got older it's funny Gianni Russa also
said in New York you would run he was a
runner at 14 15 years old for Frank
Costello's what he was doing that for
when he was doing the certain favors for
it so at what point will you kind of
like wow you know I'm running I'm doing
this but I'm seeing the lifestyle maybe
there's a bigger opportunity here where
was that opening was there anything that
was you know was it accidental was it
intentional how did it end well I didn't
have to really
after doing that I didn't have to get
any further introduction because I'm
working on making $75 a week in a deli
basically working full-time for the you
know whatever the minimum wage was back
then and if George or ro well we had a
good week and he run as he saw he was
also a professional box that he joins a
gangster and mousie know the guy when
they were having a good week they took
me 20 50 a hundred so at the end of the
week I'm getting 75 from the deli and
these guys may be on a good week of
giving me 300 and you're talking about
one on the kid when 300s like 3,000 what
year is this this is 1975 76 and he
sells a lot of money right there not a
money yeah for four 14 15 year-old kid
making 300 bucks yeah a week on top of
the 75 it's okay so now you meet Gotti
you're 17 he's 16 where does the
relation relationship go to you know
come on in let's do some more work
together how did that sup how does that
happen nickel diamond in a drug business
Albert Luciano is my but you know what
you would say umbrella and these a
couple years older than me and if I had
any issues I would bring
Dalbert at the time his dad was still
the boss and as when his dad leaves
I'm also dabbling in a bookmaking
business and Gabon has a problem with
Ghani on a street with some Jamaicans
they rob I think about two or three
hundred pounds at that time gap it
wasn't moving weed at that time what we
call weed back then and God he was his
partner they asked me to take a ride and
be the shooter with with gebet actually
I was the driver gather was the shooter
and that was the first time they asked
me to do a favor and it was really
Gabbard that was asking me to favor
because he lived around a corner from me
and he was friends with God he and
friends with me so he said we just do me
a favor and take the ride I said yeah
and we met God he to discuss how we were
gonna do it that was probably the first
major step into becoming later on
involved in setting up multiple killing
shooting seven and beatings around the
city what was the first time the request
was made like how did they know you were
the guy to go to had you already kill
people or or had never happened before
no I you know most of my friends unlike
what people think because they know my
history now they think I was a wild kid
with guns and knives and bats it was
actually the complete opposite of all my
friends around seven and nine gang my
first friend Michael Scranton ends up
killing a kid at sixteen and going to
prison another young guy Tommy Turner
kills another guy that works at Dick's
deli with us you know they try to jump
on me stabbed the guy up he went to jail
so these guys that were growing up with
me the Bonner brothers they're using
guns everybody's using guns my friend
Mikey Murillo gets shot in the head with
a shotgun chasing a guy that had the gun
so he'll tell you the mentality of us
he's chasing a guy that actually has the
shotgun with no gun and he loses his
life there so I was kind of innocent
compared to them I wasn't running around
with guns I was fighting with my hands
as I'm getting acclimated with all my
friends
I was surrounding people that are
surrounded around my life I start slowly
picking up knives bats and then I go
into the guns so after that shooting
would get it I think that opened the
door for people say oldest kid I'll do
anything
got it so what was your first experience
with knives and bats was it still in
your teens or oh yeah was in my teens
it wasn't your yes by telling mom 17 I
start using a bat like crazy too at 17
17 by the time mom 19 I've stabbed a
couple guys added a couple guys I got
stabbed up and batted myself at 19 I
almost lost my life that you know I
wasn't out at hospitals for about a year
and now I really understood the life and
I started to understand as I'm climbing
up the ladder I'm losing my cousin Patsy
adriano senior gets killed then Mikey
Murillo gets killed and Billy extreme it
gets killed and what is this doing to
you when when this is happening and
you're seeing people that are friends
family getting killed are you getting
the retaliatory are you getting the
retaliation blood and you or no you're
just kind of seeing what's going on you
got to protect yourself no I'm getting
like you're doing as a journalist and as
an interview person and you you develop
and you become top in your field right
you become somebody that's going to be
the best and you're gonna do your
homework and you're gonna study and
you're gonna make sure that you don't
make mistakes and you're gonna go it's
closer to the kinda it's a hundred
percent to be an expert in your business
so I decided I'm not gonna be the next
victim like all my friends they were all
getting killed out of stupidity and out
of trust of trust and so on you got to
cut those odds down and I said to myself
I'm gonna be very aggressive and I'm
gonna understand I'm not 14 or 15 or 16
anymore when someone comes after me they
know I'm dangerous now they're gonna
come to kill me
so who are you trusting at that time you
know we have people that you trust a
hundred percent oh yeah I had I had a
ton of guys as I'm getting older and I'm
moving in the drug business bookmaking
business right I have dozens of guys
that work for me and it goes into
hundreds later on as I keep getting
older and I'm and I start my own cruise
and with the okay or the Gambino family
so I become a big earner on the street
and I become a guy that's well known
with different crews and and I'm
trusting my guys and I'm also trusting
the mob almost blindly you know
believing that this loyalty and this
honor and there's no treachery
and I'm still naive right I'm a young
kid that loves this life believes in it
and as I start seeing some things as I'm
getting older and understanding there is
no honor its treachery there is no love
it's only about money it's only about an
individual surviving and I'm watching as
I'm going through life and getting
bigger and stronger in this life and
being more successful that I'm watching
gangster made guy you have to made yeah
you know cooperating Rati breaking the
oath laws are rules that I live by
although I'm Albanian but what was the
first request that made by maybe you
know John juniors father that came down
did you have a meeting with John senior
that have you had multiple meetings with
them Oh at this point I've met Gotti
senior Angelo Ruggiero well I got a
report to the club 24 hours a day 7 days
a week when I'm called I have to be
there early in the morning like a job I
already know some 18-plus
yeah about the 19 more 719 it's about
the time I get stabbed up and everything
and I don't come a couple of times and I
think Gotti senior at this time thinks
I'm just one of his son's friends and I
don't need to beat it and I get a knock
on my door and it's my grandmother
upstairs we live in the same house and
she says Johnny there's a big black car
outside then there's somebody's out
there so I go out there and it's Gotti
senior's brothers that's Pete Gotti and
Ritchie Gotti at the time both guys
aren't me guys and they said to him a
way to [ __ ] all you and his brothers yes
what are you talking about he says my
brother's look up here and I look at him
funny like and then I start realizing
wait a second you know to myself with
split second and I go back upstairs and
I come down and I says let's go
and they said you know he wants to talk
to you that's what I realized that I'm
just not some kid to him I'm not his
son's friend we're not in a gang this is
not a you know a school trip now I'm
starting to really realize this guy's
noticing me and he's watching what I'm
doing and I'm still not understanding it
these orders I'm getting collect money
go baseball bat this guy go pick up this
is actually coming from the father you
know I just think it's us too
our own business on her own Jeannie God
he's still alive still around at the
time he's not locked up yet and I just
believe it's that and then I started
opens my eyes and said this guy is he's
very aware of what we're doing he's very
aware that we're moving drugs just says
he is it because I'm not schooled fully
yet I'm still a kid not understanding
the intricacies of the Mafia I'm not
understanding
I'm not slick enough yet to understand
how things are operating you say
something but you might mean something
else you're doing something and they're
telling you they had no knowledge of it
but they're the ones that sent you I
start understanding all the double
dealings and the treachery in the life
who's teaching you like who is your
lefty - Donnie Brasco or your sunny
who's playing that role in your life
that is kind of mentoring you say like
here's what it is here's what America is
here's a code of this here's this who is
who's doing that with you well it was a
guy Ronnie Martino who's a known killer
back in the Dick's deli and Gambino
family know outside and again be no
family he had a brother-in-law that was
involved with the Gambino family but he
was involved with the Lucchese family
and I had a lot of Lucchese he had a
brother Gambino in his Lucchesi not a
brother a brother-in-law a
brother-in-law got it and you know it's
not what everybody thinks it's not you
know most of there's five families in
New York there's the outfit in Chicago
there's a Philadelphia mob Cavalcanti
family in North Jersey well we all
mingle into them intermingle with each
other we do business with each other
we're friends with each other but we
also kill each other on orders so
it'sit's it's not as simple and cut and
dry that people there's a lot of people
out there that think they know the mob
and they think they understand that and
there's people that are so naive and
there's people that think there are
experts in this world and it's life
there's guys like Sammy Gravano was a
friend of mine and other guys that there
are ex skippers and bosses and on the
bosses that we're all touch with and we
live that life and even us we have daily
problems understanding the life in the
treachery and as we all got out of the
life and moved on with our lives or our
friends died or got killed you know
these people that challenged us and
these days you know you could challenge
anybody through a computer well they
talk
they just talk such nonsense because
they have no idea or clue of the
treachery that involves when you get to
the level that we were playing at so and
so what's the next place so now they're
coming the brothers are coming you're in
the car you're like I got to go these
guys he knows what's going on the orders
are coming from the top you go in so now
there's almost a level of accountability
from his end and the son is a friend but
it's not you're not yet reporting to
anybody or are you well now I start
reporting it's about close to Paul
Castle I know getting killed so it's the
end of 84 about prior to Paul getting
killed I start reporting and having
conversations Norwood senior Gotti prior
to that I was involved with Jeannie
Gotti Johnny Canaria anybody that was
around Willie boy Johnson was on a half
sheet with him and gaudy senior sent me
to him so I understood that God he was
my poly not the father and we had the
New York Mets gambling with me so so
when I moved to a different level we
used to play it we used to hang out a
place called channel ad and it was a
known spot for also gangsters you'd pull
up with a boat we all had cigarette
boats in those days I had a 280 Baja
with Gotti junior and we'd pull up to
those places and Rodger pasilla loaned
it he was around Jimmy Burke from
Goodfellas his son Frankie was a good
friend of mine he gets killed also and I
start understanding that we're all
living a pretty dangerous life now any
moment anybody could get killed didn't
matter who it was where it was in your
house in a business and it's not like
these days where guys aren't shooting
when we were growing up 70s 80s 90s
there was killing was rampant shootings
were rapid and batting's were rampant so
when I'm doing business and I'm talking
to Willie boy Johnson I understand where
it's coming from him and Gotti had his
conversations what Lisa why I'm the
senior had his conversations with me so
I understand the orders are coming from
did you know were you involved in in the
Castellano before it happened with Sam
Ian and the team was there anything that
you know about it that was an actual
level yet no I was at my level it was
but it was through his
Jr loved to talk to me in practice so
private least jr. told me I knew I'm
involved with Angelo Ruggiero so I was
close with them I'm close with Johnny
connect at this time I gave a beatin -
Patsy catalano's kid Jeff who was in
heroin business a genie Gotti and Johnny
could against me to hurt him I gave a
beatin to a guy Frankie you know these
beatings are serious beings not what
your hands bad that's black Jack's a guy
Frankie that's straight away from Johnny
Kinnear and they asked me to hurt him I
know the guy Mitch Sanders they asked me
to hurt him over some sort of rape with
his girlfriend's sister they accused him
they go ask and they asked the Gambino
family due to work Johnny comes to me so
I start understanding I heard Jean
Foster on a beach and I started hurting
guys and baton guys and piping guys and
it's coming from at that time I didn't
really understand what's coming from God
he's senior until until he didn't like
that I didn't jump on a situation fast
enough and he called me in his office
and he said did my son tell you to do
something and then the next conversation
I had was if it's not done you even have
a problem so I took care of business of
seniors told you yeah and then I went
through that over to the races no he's a
beating still oh you still haven't new
you still haven't knows I'm doing
shootings but I haven't killed any black
besides the gibbet and he was actual
shooter so I don't know how many guys
died on that shooting but you know we
had I believe three guys and maybe a
girl actually was there so you know you
don't stand back there and count how
many guys are going down you know
they're going down there screaming and
he shoot like crazy so that's your first
one that is my fresh I was young I was
19 years old what happened when that
happened to you were you like I cannot
believe I just did this what what the
hell just happened were you I was mad
because I talked about this Gotti and a
kid Jerry was following us in a cake all
junior and it was supposed to be our
blockers
and they took off and made a left when a
police with Jason's happened - please
just stumbled on us they were coming in
the direction of shooting it wasn't if
we weren't fall from the precincts from
a hundred second priests and so there's
a lot of police cause there I mean for
them to be coming down a block at that
time you got some bad
look so after we do the shooting I would
think you know I wasn't sure how I would
react either like you saying naturally
you're not sure are you gonna hold your
mud or are you gonna panic or you gonna
it became very natural to me it was very
easy I pulled away the cops were chasing
us gabot left the gun in my car he
jumped out well it was moving that was
going slow down a one-way street not
slow but I was coming up to the stop
sign
and he jumped out he said let me out as
he jumped out he left the gun and the
cops started chasing me and my my follow
call and my backup car was supposed to
be got eNOS get Jerry and they had an
excuse why they jumped out so really I'm
the only guy holding a mud and I was
heading down towards Atlantic Avenue was
the one I know the streets take because
we lived there and I know it's in one
way I open up the passenger door I open
up the other door I take the gun and I
start huffing on my feet and I leave the
cause of the cops can't go by I great
across Atlantic Avenue I start jumping
fences some backyards and I'm taking the
gun apart and drop it in and so as I'm
running and I get myself back to our
club 113th Street and I'm steaming and I
says now I won't gap it this is the
first time I'm saying okay I'm going to
get gutted so gabot came to the shooting
hi he was smoking dust and he's a wild
guy you know no doubt I know Kevin since
he's a kid he's a shooter he shot a lot
of guys but he's a you know he's a
guided smoking angel toasties so I look
at him in a different light now you know
weak you can't do work without doing
that you left me and I'm looking at God
it you know I'm thinking that's all I'm
thinking and why I stick around is
because I have a bigger plan for myself
because everybody asked me that question
why do you stick around I says because
jr. wasn't my direction his father was
the direction I was trying to go and
Angelo Ruggiero at the time is moving
heroin with Jeannie Gotti Joanie connect
they will get pinched walk writer and
I'm very friendly with them and I'm
moving some I stopped moving packages
not net level in small levels but I'm
moving it to Rikers Island through
another guy that said Rikers Island uh a
guy Chrissy Pete Chrissy he's dead he
died also but his brothers are still
around there's
his work for me actually one of his
brothers Tommy Chrissy shot give it up
before we kill him on what was on a kill
and when we see him which he lived but
uh I'm in a different circle and I
understand what what I'm involved with
now what Angela would Johnny and the
shooting start the drug business starts
so I understand and I know where I want
to go I got the New York Mets gambling
with me and actually somebody questioned
that I don't remember who and they came
out with a check from Keith Hernandez of
$5,000 to show they were paying they
found the $5 he put it was in papers it
was in the real papers
so that's documented it's documented you
know a lot of this stuff um speaking
about this a new book I'm coming out
with rocket talks now it to and I'm
gonna come back this time you know
because I'm gonna talk about shooting
after shooting stabbing after stabbing
but this time I told my author I want
the witnesses and their names
besides the victims in that book and I'm
gonna do a scorecard inside so I'm gonna
show it step by step the teachers don't
understand the life so at that moment
when that event happened with Gotti
junior is your level of trusting him at
a good score and then after that it's a
scar will you kind of keep it in the
back your minds and I can never trust
this guy like where are you with him
because there are certain things where
you see somebody do something about your
mind like okay it's done I can never
trust this guy but I have to act like I
do it is that kind of what happened we
told the two of you a hundred percent
because people ask you this you know
during the trials they were there's a
lot of questions for our lawyers and
journalists and you know and I said to
him listen I tell everybody the same
thing you had all the positions before
this as a kid you're growing up and this
bosses you don't respect you don't trust
and you keep it down the back it's just
a lesson learned that you know that you
can't trust them you know that he's not
he doesn't belong in this life as the
years are moving on and not even years
as the months and weeks are going on I
just named probably half a dozen of our
friends had already dead by the time the
next year comes around I can name
another six seven guys that are dead so
here's
piers good friends and some of these
friends of mine are guys later on that I
kill or I have killed you know I had
like Johnny gebet I have him killed at
one time he was my friend as a kid he
lived around the corner from me but you
starting to understand the life and you
starting to stand at ready and your
understanding
just like at war that this is your not
at playing a game no more you're not the
schoolyard
you're not gonna punch a guy in the face
and it's gonna end so you start really
understanding when you can't trust
somebody you don't say it you don't talk
only the guys that talk dead so you know
I always use the on force I got a lot of
respect for these guys and I've talked
about it on a regular basis Armed Forces
because these guys every day
put on a uniform whether they see action
know action they have the possibility to
lose in their life so when people sit in
their comfortable homes and they don't
salute a flag or they don't get up and
respect on people in armed forces around
the world not just this country Isis I
despise them they're cowards and I have
strong feelings against them because
these men they lost their mothers
fathers kids children and we have no
right in the matter what and I lived a
rough life on the street and no matter
what this country has done to me as far
as prisons and I'll never disrespect the
flag or the people that fight for our
country so it's very important and I
think that the message of somebody's
people leave out the street about
something they don't understand this
it's important to get the right message
out there John at that moment when
you're when you're seeing what happened
with a UN Gotti junior was there a
moment where the next time you saw him
what he couldn't look at you in their
eyes was there anything like that word
the tension was felt or no you acted
like everything was okay like even a
smile like you just made right now that
smile tells 50 stories right so you know
what I'm saying when you see somebody
and there's a smirk or smile or squint
or angle of looking at him is there any
that felt between the two of you or
nothing at all yeah I asked them what
happened he gave me an answer I know it
was [ __ ] and I didn't question
anymore I just put it in the bank and
said okay I know what he's made of now
so I understood at that moment that
he'll sell me out
any second anytime and later on he does
yeah so so so then this leads me to the
next question now you're saying in that
moment you're you have bigger ambitions
on what you want to do right you're
saying I have bigger ambitions but
you're Albanian right it's there's you
can't be a made man and again be no
family and be Albanian you've got to be
Italian right I mean that's one of the
things that they had them so special E
to go be a boss to be the boss it's a
complete different story so as much as
you're motivated and ambitious to do it
what was your formula on how to get to
the top no I understood technically I
couldn't be officially made technically
but otherwise and every other aspect of
that street world I'm considered being
made yeah I'm considered being almost a
boss on the street I'm considered by
anybody in the mall because you know
what runs runs the world of the Mafia is
violence violence and money so if you
can I had the qualities that other guys
that I was intelligent so I know how to
make money I don't know how to operate
businesses and I was vicious
so those qualities make me become
another Jimmy Burke who was Robert De
Niro Goodfellas who know of course yeah
his son was my good friend so I looked
at Jimmy Burke I don't see I don't think
there was anybody ever when he was in
jail on the streets would ever say oh
you're Irish
we're not respecting you as a gangster
as a mob guy well Joe Watts who was a
very personal friend and a known killer
in our family and John Gotti senior's
main guy and he was German
so there's guys that I looked at and
said I'm going to be done and I did
become then the guys testified in trials
in court that I had my own crew when it
was very unusual for an Albanian and non
Italian to be able to run their own
crews on a street and always challenge
but those guys and his groups outside of
you know you see some of these mob sites
and the guys they don't even know what
they're speaking about this there was
you know the Westies and Irish group at
New York Manhattan I would laugh if
somebody ever typed something to them
back in the 80s that they're they're not
respected because they're Irish and even
we'll talk about these days the last
four hits
American Italian mafia what done by
black guys so I want to see those same
guys telling them well we're not gonna
respect them people in the street and
this is anybody in the street
well the Hells Angels my friend was he
just passed away was grow up me since
what kids was president Hells Angels I
don't want to see I don't think there's
anybody in it from the screen that is
really a legitimate tough guy that
doesn't on the standard Street we
understand to respect somebody would
intelligence and somebody that is on the
street that's it's tough so regardless
no one says to you well what's your
nationality I'm gonna respect you for
your national I don't know that about it
but but there's it they're like you know
Mira you you you you know Tony Mirra you
know there were certain guys that were
known for being earners there were
certain guys for being known for being
soldiers right there are guys that knew
how to go make the money and some of
them that knew how to take the hits one
of the things Sammy was known for the
guy the reason why he got so much street
credit is and this is this comes from
everybody I talk to whoever I talk to
for whatever reason they all either
respects and Sammy and validate what he
did and even the whole story with him
and got him going and testifying
immunity whatever you want to call it
for the 19 counts they say he ran a
legitimate construction company was
making money and at the same time when
it came down to tune the job he did it
as well so but because he was Italian he
could eventually end up being a boss
what was your you know and of you know
my vision is one day John la it's gonna
be XYZ what was your ocean I'll tell you
something cuz you mentioned Sammy Sammy
Gravano and this is the first time I
mention that anyway Sammy Gravano did an
interview his first one since he's been
home from his 15 years he just did and
his interview was about Johnny Lee he
does a Oreo interview with a guy named
Andy DeLeon oh the perfect gangster won
that interview was gonna be in Europe
shortly and he discusses what I am and
what's a thug what's a mafioso what's a
gangster and he says most people this is
his words
or uh either like a Michael Franzese
who's a mafia mafioso erna
but not a killer he doesn't put a gun in
his hand he's a very intelligent man I
like him I respect him he speaks well he
turned his life around he's doing the
right thing and then there's guys like
Frank Cullotta who's thug gangster
killer so there's two types
Sammy gave me in that interview he said
about me that I'm both I'm an earner I'm
a thug and I'm a mafioso and I'm an all
banging mafioso that has total respect
from the mob world and that I'm a
professional hitman and I'm the killer
and I'm the Gambino's families hit
Bennett I know unfortunately I was
around the wrong guys the Gottis those
are his words not mine those those are
recorded words how many total people
have you done a how many hits did you do
total you're different now yeah 15 us
you know you get TV here's the thing you
know you go play baseball
and I've tried to say this is you know
so many different times when I'm talking
you will play baseball and a guy plays
one game and he gets a base hit he's
gonna remember it up for his Russells
likes only game he played I did this day
in and day out so when someone said did
you kill Georgie Grasso I'll give you
names that he should I'm gonna head yes
I did did somebody say did you kill
Johnny Gavin yes I did I ordered him
dead did you kill Bruce got her up
unfortunately how friends were his
family now yes I did I ordered him dead
did you shoot Michael alig me in the
chest and porticos he testified against
you 25 years yes I did
did you shoot Ricky Stratton in the head
only at the ballpark way Johnny I did
you shoot him yes I did
did you shoot Paul G in front of John
Gotti senior's house and you didn't care
what's in front of us house yes I did
did you shoot Nicky Pasquale five times
on his porch and he lose his leg and he
almost died yes I did did you stab a guy
in front of Vinny butch in Fort
Lauderdale in the neck in the stomach
and he was operated twice and almost
died yes I did
did you shoot cell no Rose
brother-in-law and
bulkhead ball yes I did I shot his
friend outside the bulkhead ball yes I'd
I could go on with these names and if I
did I show two guys in front of
mondello's for Michael counter panel we
call cat man still alive yes I did
witnesses that I baseball about three
bikers and by baseball bat Nicky
Kenny Nicole on 78th Street in front of
old brother and by accident yes I did
he's alive joy Mathis his dad I went to
protect them then I piped three guys and
hit him with bottles and throw it
princeton diner frontally symmetry dziak
her best friends married to Joe puja
Toria captain in a Philadelphia mob she
was there still alive yes I did did I
stab a biker in Forest Hills in the
thigh and tell him I'll shoot him and I
had never come looking for me again
after that baseball by the other three
bikers yes I did Michael Finney
testified against it for it about what I
did did I shoot my pip and two other
guys in front one hundred sixteen 101st
Avenue yes I did see the difference
between what I do and I can go on we
could keep talking I don't know how many
guys I shot I killed two guys for sure
on my property maybe three Danny Morel
unlike some of the stories that said
that never happened
testified and he's on tape it'll be out
in perfectly gangsta to Dino Finelli
helped me get rid of the guns after
we've seen tons of blood all over these
are regular guys don't the guns for me
testified also and did an interview on
tape calming groan multimillionaire
legitimate guy owns Tomatoes restaurant
testified I did he was out the property
Steve Locke Rotondo insurance man
regular guy testified I did so you know
when guys are talking at a line or out
of school I hear it all the time so why
is Sammy Gravano the underboss of family
talking about me than that in that way
why did Ronnie want on captain in a
Gambino family I robbed all his book me
because he was a one-time friend of mine
I robbed Jojo Corrado at one time
constantly of the family robbed his
bookmakers what anybody get any
retaliation against me I robbed two of
them I put my name in his mouth and I
taped it
Steve Catalano was there he's still
alive Johnny perks in jail even though I
don't like the kid
he was then he didn't want to come near
the guy because the guy was too big so
these guys are alive I couldn't go on
why did Ronnie 100 in his own words and
his opening statements a fight nights to
Johnny a lady he'll kill me like he
killed everybody else why did he say in
a dozen times get his paperwork in his
opening statement it's out all over the
Internet then I'm John Gotti Jr's part
I'm in the partners in a drug business
over and over and over again he repeated
it
why did Stevie Newell guy I shot who I'm
personally friends what now and we had a
disagreement the god he said they were
protect them I shot him did he say on
tape
you don't know Johnny hey don't shoot
anybody anywhere and did and John Gotti
Jr ratted on him write it on me or
became a rat he called Stevie Iraq
wasn't true
why did Stevie Newell say that he sees
captains in a Gambino family answer to
me he grew up in our neighborhood so
when guys talk and I hear these tough
guys on the Internet and you got guys
like Vito ghazal who's doing 30
something years he's been my enemy for
years then I have him shot yes did he
kill the guy I had him shot yes he did
do I like him not not particularly do I
know him since he's five six years old
yes does he have the right to talk about
me he does because he was a legitimate
gangster whether I like it or not and he
knows his own illegitimate gang said
they tried to kill me seven eight ten
times how many times these guys were on
America's Most Wanted anything tobita
Frankie for Adele oh there's a serious
guys kill us but when you get guys like
bigmouth there's a kid from my
neighborhood Frankie JDC who's a punk
what a big mouth never did anything and
they talk like they ever did anything he
never loaded a gun he's another guy only
guys that talk like that you know
they're about nothing but when at least
if they're in the mix and you don't want
his friend was getting hurt well we
would collected money off him he ran he
hid in front of a hundred six priests
and these same guys that talk when they
talk about my children my children ain't
gangsters you got children too so when
they talk out of school they're you know
they're not about anything because guys
that run their mouths they're nothing
the guys at free togas oh who was a
legitimate killer I didn't particularly
like their crimes I didn't like a lot of
those guys and that crew did some of
them didn't like it either with Vinny
what Vito was doing but you can say to
yourself this guy is a gangster he can't
talk there's a guy out of Brooklyn
that's in the street still I know him
since when kid I won't say it's only was
Annie he was a kill a tough guy so he
has the legitimate right to talk about
the street but these guys that don't
know what they're talking about because
I can run those lists on and on and on
of guys I shot baseball bat and I said I
baseball bat at over a hundred guys
instead did I do it well people say did
it and there's a guy Johnny to test the
fight for John Gotti junior high
baseball bat at him by myself the three
guys I just talked about by myself the
Krzyzanowski brothers i baseball bat at
two by myself
the keegan brothers i baseball batter
one them by myself I could go on that's
why I said I mean I'm gonna say names
this time to shut these people up they
don't know what they're talking about or
disrespect me because my life is
different now the hard part for me is
not to kill these guys that talk the
easy part for me was killing guys and
hurting guys why was it easy that's part
of my life was like putting on a uniform
and going around me whether I it's a
crazy way of thinking when I signed up
for his life I believed in it I don't
believe in it anymore there's two things
that ruin this life that people don't
understand structure right and fear
there is no more fear because they're
asking people outside of the mob to do
that killing from the do that [ __ ] the
shooting for them weight structure and
fear is what made it work or strong
native wonder what it's what melee don't
work why it doesn't work now is because
I can name and I can see how I just
named all the guys I shot instead then I
could have kept going right you could
see I could keep rambling these names
that same guy this ain't the way I did
that I can name family after family Joe
Mussina acting boss boss excuse me of
the Bonanno family became a rat John
Gotti Jr became a rat al d'arco Lucchese
family a rat Philadelphia mob Ralph
Natali's
rat Leonetti rat how you gonna have
structure when all your bosses are right
not only the bosses I can go down the
line at captain's I can go to my keys
cause became a cooperator
I won't call him I ride Coco opera he
was John Gotti juniors best friend he
made statements I was there when we were
setting up juries for Gotti senior why
is he making that statement of home a
nobody if I'm not this guy everybody
says well why is he saying that Johnny a
light he was there and we were gonna
hit Curtis Lee when I denied it I said
I'm not hitting a journalist we got
enough guys we can hit and kill so why
am i at weddings
why I'm at the Gatti's wedding Wyman
sisters so when people talk out of line
they don't have a clue what they talk
they have no idea the violence that we
were living and what I personally did
for the Gambino family in jails out of
jails John let me ask you I'm listening
to the way you say it you're saying it a
way a baseball player would say you know
game three playoffs round you know
such-and-such I hit the double and it
scored a winning run you know Game one
opener against the Yankees I hit a you
know home run and we ended up winning I
went three for four the way you're
saying it it's just so nonchalant is
that a part of it where in your world
there is it almost sounds it's like I
don't want to say bragging rights but
it's like listen I'm a real soldier
here's what I really did because you
lived in doubt I feel the competitive
spirit that you have I feel the the the
spirit of look I'm legit here's what I
did I was a driven guy I was committed
to the life and I wanted to come through
and I'm not one of these guys that
didn't that were afraid to be soldiers I
did this part as well that's that's that
that's the way it comes across are these
things where for you during that part of
the world you look at and you say I
chose to live this life and I'm proud of
the job I did is that kind of how you're
processing it or no my father let me go
back to my father my father taught me to
be best at whatever I did so when I
played baseball you have to beat me for
me to back away from a guy come in a
home plate when I was a little kid in a
catcher there's no way I'm going to step
away and so I tagged him when I was in
the ring whether win or lose they put me
in a ring one time with a kid that was
destroying me my trainer wasn't there
and it was you know just boring mm-hmm
and I wouldn't I refuse not to go in the
ring
and he beat me all over the ring and
then when I got involved with the mob I
believe he's the thing that why I'm so
adamant the way I talk and what I say
and it's because I believed in the mob
more than anybody I went against my
family I went on the run because I
didn't want to
of anybody no mom I left all my money
millions
I left my children I stayed in a
Brazilian penitentiary and I was gonna
rot there
I was willing to face it that sentence I
lived in every country you could think
of meanwhile my enemies and my friends
like Gotti junior we're already
cooperating so what I'm trying to do and
it's so important for me to say I am the
real deal I am the guy that did this
it's not bragging and you know if maybe
sometimes it comes off that way because
I'm angry because I go around now I
don't know if you know what I generate
because I go around and I teach kids
don't follow that's why I'm angry
because I don't want kids to follow this
life I don't want kids to understand and
think that these guys are tough guys
because in my book that I'm gonna do
with Susan Pike I'm gonna come out with
the next book this is darkest hour one
I'm coming out with stalkers out two and
three and the darkest hour - that's
coming out in February I'm gonna put a
scorecard like we doing sports when
somebody gets just what you said how
many hits or how many tackles I want to
go through how many these guys never
touched a gun in their life never did a
killing Pete Gotti say never touched a
gun you didn't kill anybody
it's easy put to ask this kid to do the
killing from it was easy to ask me to do
the killing and the shooting and then
when it's finished and all the trouble
starts say he was nobody because they're
gonna do it to the next kid that's why
I'm so was saying or nobody whoever says
it I'm saying it doesn't matter who
saying what I'm trying to teach these
kids is don't follow this life I'm here
to tell you I lived this life I wrote a
guy who was in this life making a ton of
money this is a dead end way to live so
it's very important to be very strong
about the way I'm talking and what I've
done and it's very important to let
these kids know listen do not follow
this this is a one-way street to nowhere
and it's very tough to live that life
today though you know - to have the mob
life today it's very tough to live the
life to this what not not as it was in
the 80s no it's not as the 80s because
they're not killing and they're not
shooting and they're not baseball bat
security well this is why I was talking
about structure and fear right but you
have guys all over street selling powder
and pills and they think they're
gangsters they put on a suit and tie
they put on a cigar they
put a cigar in their mouth and they
think they gangsters and teaching these
kids they could still do this and you
can have a future but there is no future
in this life there is no future in
selling drugs there's no future in
selling or hurting its this is why I
said it's very easy to kill and hurt but
the hard part is not to Jen what's your
filing out what caused the fall I've
read many different things
and I've read both sides of the story
you know and I called around just to
kind of see what they're gonna tell me
people that don't believe a single word
that comes out of your mouth people that
say this guy's legit and I've called
names that you know some of the names
you've mentioned just to kind of give
that but they've asked me to not
disclose the names for obvious reasons
like if I were to call you and say hey
what do you think about this this is
what I'm sitting with yours what's the
case with this guy what what caused a
falling-out with you John and senior
what what caused the follow not while
you're coming up well it's very simple I
mean anybody would an education can
decipher what I'm saying a check right
because I'm making statements with names
I'm making statements of choice okay
here's the falling out Frankie to Chico
was killed did you see anybody get
killed after Frankie got blown up
no any Lina was killed by little Casey
family by the road cops at bolito see
anybody retaliate that no Bobby
Borriello was killed in front of his
house see anybody retaliate that no Joey
scope what it was put in position to be
an acting boss at a Colombo family by
gaudí
when he was murdered in front of his
house any retaliation no my good friend
great ride he was chopped up and left
somewhere nobody had found his body
while his father did life didn't give up
God he's seen you could have never spent
one day mark writer in prison and nobody
did anything about it
and in my belief they ordered it they
okayed it they didn't order the murder
of Greg write it but they okayed it and
I could go on with that list little
Anthony Medusa was killed over a dispute
and I'm trying to think of bedrocks with
the owner did anybody kill the guy that
killed him regardless if the guy was
wrong the right outlaws you can't put
your hands on a made guy he killed him
god I didn't do anything about it nobody
did anything about it why not so we
believe in nothing we
believe in money and these kids think
that this loyalty I just named every
boss that's right I just named Sammy
Gravano let's put out somebody in his
shoes he was quiet he never got caught
on tapes he didn't brag he didn't talk
about murders that we committed in the
past
that it's it's all law if you do bring
it up you're killed for it he didn't go
against his boss he was a big moneymaker
he was a family man he didn't run around
like a lot of us they were woman he was
a perfect gangster that guy was a
perfect accident and he was quiet now
he's known to be a rat right that's what
the the journalists around the world
projected a mess that's what the
gangsters did but who's really direct
this guy did everything from God he gave
him up every which way and he didn't get
a chance to kill Gotti maybe if he got a
chance to he wouldn't ever spoke but
instead he was in handcuffs gonna do ten
life sentences because of Gotti's big
mouths because he betrayed Sammy Gravano
Sammy don't betray anybody wait wait did
you just say if Sammy had the chance to
kill God he would up of course he would
have Raja beside do you think Sammy was
a threat to Gotti because the street saw
Sammy more as the power guy then got it
because Sammy was getting all the
context and relay like he could
eventually be a boss or not no because
Sammy didn't have an ego he had no
aspirations to take over you didn't care
to John what he did on one of your ball
Oh Sammy I know is that known it was
known because Sammy didn't have the ego
Sam you stood back Sammy only cared
about making money staying what is fair
how much time did you spend with Sammy
oh but he is I was he was always around
like I was around I you know you walking
with your buddies where you thought
wasn't at all I was loyal to the Gottis
so for me to say this I was a gaudy
loyalist
I wasn't a Sammy Gravano loyalist but
you know if you're gonna speak about the
mob and honestly in history history
needs to be correct right it can't be
somebody that's in love with the the
romance of the Gotti story I mean you
said something about the Gottis which is
which is quite interesting you said
anything that preserves Gotti Junior's
image is glorifying the mob if you're
glorifying the mob you're killing kids
you're teaching kids to respect the
coward you're calling John Gotti junior
and senior coward is that is that what
you're saying
like they were cowards listen I'm
calling all MCAT was the Gottis I'm
calling Jeanne Gowdy account he was in
jail with me he was my cellmate I
slapped him around in jail I didn't slap
around just talk yeah Teddy Persico was
there call my person goes brother Mikey
Spinelli and no one killer was there
patty della ruse will make guys they're
all that lets somebody ask him did I do
it
that I have Louis and Dino from GQ we
used to call Rob Jeanne Gotti did have
James Perry slap and throw a chair at
him that I have mark Giuliani to it did
we beat up and hurt ally Calabrese in
jail you see him in the irishman they
talk about he's a gangsters gangster
nobody did nothing about it why not
these guys were all there wasn't they
everybody knows the story so when people
say when they talk when they don't have
knowledge of what they're speaking about
but I'm speaking from facts and I ask
people look it up Pete God he never used
a gun never John Gotti see never killed
anybody with his own hand John Gotti
senior never never with his own hand
it's easy to have somebody else do it
here I'll give you go until you kill
zero he's never zero how would you know
that I know everything about him was
he's dead where's everybody that's the
part somebody may say he doesn't have
you're going after a guy that's dead he
can't defend them son gun
all right he's dead let him come out
this FBI alive but there's so many rats
out there joe massino's a rat knows him
his whole life all right
why isn't he talking about al d'arco why
is he talking about but there's a
million guys out there that hung around
all the guys had cooperated around the
Gambino family nobody put a gun in got
his hand to ever I was friendly with
Willie boy Johnson before he cooperated
well he was cooperating we all were and
when he spouted off or Angelo Ruggiero
spouted off they all said the same thing
but I'm not I'm talking about facts
because you have FBI information you
have guys that ratted you have guys that
stayed with him you have you have common
Agnello never used a gun his
brother-in-law he ran to Cleveland had a
16 count indictment they closed the
courtroom what did he do to get out of
it he got guns in his house I mean these
are facts these aren't you know so when
kids are looking up at these guys I'm
some don't you open your eyes cuz I
never opened my eyes until now and now
that I have a voice I could save kids
lives but but why why is the stone
being told otherwise why why is a why is
this story being told because isn't one
of the criterias of being a made man you
have to kill somebody isn't that one of
the criteria so it's not know so you can
be a made man and a boss and you've
never killed anybody
correct okay the second thing isn't one
of the codes of being a mobster you can
never talk to a government official FBI
copy you can never do that
never do that jr. sitting with the FBI
make it thrilled to as where I'm sitting
Brazil Penitentiary and he could give me
20 life sentences so tell me who
betrayed who I'm in a jail I'm in a
dungeon I'm getting he's saying he
didn't say anything and nobody got
arrested afterwards that's what he says
that nothing happened that's what he
wouldn't say you know you know yourself
okay you find me one gangster because he
could tell that the Republicans right
only but we know our laws he sat with
them he gave information against us he
was an informant just like Willie boy
Johnson and we all cop please Joe Watts
had a cop to a murder
Danny Moreno had a cop to a murder
because of John's testimony and he
refused to get on a stand against him he
only wanted to feed information that's
the truth he was locked up for the
silver fox he stabbed a kid from behind
as children it's an open murder he can
never get locked up for it why not
Kevin Bona testified against all of us
great witness his girlfriend great
witness they were all that there was
Emily testimonies that they said they'd
seen him stabbed and he admitted and
tomatoey admitted he did it he stabbed
him he killed him so why isn't he
getting arrested for that murder what
ask law enforcement get an explanation
but I have his 302s we put in a book
documents of what he was saying people
he was giving up politicians he was
giving up all the guys he was giving up
he gave up his friends he put all the
friends at a murder investigation that's
still open that can is never closed and
he put them all at that location so for
him to say to the media first if he did
say he did right
actually on video said he ratted then he
said he only ratted a little then he
said he only ratted against his enemies
and then he went back and said I was
just trying to trick the FBI it's it's
it's not even a conversation to have
here at it it's stupid he sat with the
government he made a deal he
act up on the deal five different times
but that's really not the the issue is
not what he just did at that time of
writing the issue is one after another
these guys aren't using guns one after
another these guys bosses not just the
Gottis bosses around each family already
and they're trying to take guys like me
to do the killing to do the shooting to
do the beating and say he's nobody and
then use those kids to get life
sentences for them and these guys walk
away and they make deals on the side
like God he did John how many how much
time I I went away that somebody put in
at six years for this three years but
it's not true I want to wait for three
and a half years for a gun I went away
in Brazil for two and a half years I
came home I did ten years here for this
case I went in and out of jail for an
assault in 1991 I went back in 2001 I
went out again in 2002 back in jail so
when these guys talk how much total time
so I'll talk about 18 years and how come
it's 18 years if you've killed so many
people why are you not doing life
because I'm the first guy to say when
Gotti ratted they came when I came back
to United States and whatever happens
this one Brazil extradited a guy to me
back and I got the paperwork of godî
ratting when I was in Brazil they flew
him they showed it to you they showed
the constantly of the excuse me the
constituion the family Joseph carazzo
his son joke Rizzo was a lawyer
defending ronnie true guilt at the trial
in Tampa I was absentee Ronnie Juana's
opening statement was given junior up
because jr. was ratting he gave me up on
a drug in because I gave permission they
give me up but I didn't give him
permission to give me up on murders and
he started giving me up on murders but
that information the whole family knows
he's a rat he's been shelved he's been
chased did people want to kill him of
course they wanted to kill him will they
kill him who know they don't know what
information he gave well they kill who
Junior junior because people had daisya
life today today always he's always
gonna have something's gonna kill him
today well you listen it's Persico die
cali died I mean it's calm well he's
already killed but unfortunately he died
cuz I really thought he was a decent guy
that's what lot of people tell me they
say is a really decent guy I
I think the holy trying to turn it
around well I I speak openly honestly
you know faction of gentlemen they're
quiet they don't bother nobody what they
do for a living I can't judge them all
I'm judging is when guys are telling
guys put a pistol in your hair and tell
the kid to kill I'm telling the kids
don't go into the life
I'm not telling an adult don't stay in
that life I'm not how are you alive
so you've killed all these guys I mean
it's not a short list of people if
you've had a baseball bat a hundred
people you know if you do something to
my family and I'm in that world I don't
know how long you know so how come
nobody has retaliated to you if you have
this many numbers of hits how come
you're still around you're a public
figure you live in in New York it's not
like you're living in Montana listen
because I'm not P Gotti people know I'm
vicious and if you come after me and you
don't kill me they know that I'm gonna
probably do something well I understand
but that's it that's a pretty quick fix
though right if somebody says so just
make sure he doesn't live well who's
gonna kill me P Johnny no he's I mean if
he was out he's in jail know who Jackie
knows you never used the gun either who
Mikey's cause no he never used it got
commenting no he never used the gun
right you gotta go find so many years
not asking this to try to create an
event I'm asking this question too but
if I was worried about that obviously I
think III give you a lot of credit for
that because and not that others who go
and live in another place it's you know
it's to look to each his own but you
decide to stay in a place like that you
know one that one of the things I was
thinking about when I was looking at
this I got a couple of the questions
we'll go through here but one of the
things I was thinking about when I was
looking at this is sometimes the the
person to be the most careful with and I
and I want to preface it in a way and
you can come back and answer it in any
way you want
I just wanna I just want to hear your
thoughts on this sometimes say there's a
kid who you know he's got a brother and
the brothers born in America and he's
not born in America but this kids more
driven to be a president and this family
the father is pressuring them to be a
president one day and this brother knows
no matter what he does he can't ever
become a president even though he wants
to be
president Morton he wants to become a
president but he can because he was born
here this guy wasn't it's a law you
can't do nothing about it right okay
and sometimes this guy on this side who
maybe have more qualities to be a
president that his father wants him to
be they want to make father proud right
here I want to be the guy that become
comes through and leaves a legacy for
your last name pops you came here from
another country I'm gonna do my part
Germany whatever you want to talk about
it in the book 40 laws of power I don't
know if you've read the book 40 laws of
power Robert Greene law number one never
outshine the master right do you think
there was a little bit of that spirit
felt about you or no that wasn't at all
because did they kind of get a feel
enough tension to say this guy's a
little too ambitious you know and was
that kind of your frustration to say you
know if I can't go out there and you
know get all the way to the top screw it
I'm gonna go out there and throw
everybody under the bus how much of it
was that and again if you completely
disagree I'd love to hear your views on
this you know what I'm saying yes I
right you gotta understand in any aspect
of life envious people and jealous
people are dangerous people right so
when they see that I was successful they
see I was making money they see I was
dangerous they see then I had a big crew
of people more than Gotti's counties
didn't have it John Gotti Jr if you can
find me a killer that was around him
besides Bobby Borriello cuz Bobby was
killed but he Robbie wasn't a kid that
could go on a street and baseball John
you were saying you were bigger than God
he's senior in June you know no no I'm
not saying that you seen you had a ton
of guys junior didn't have guys junior
had not assured around them but I was
making more money than a senior no no
okay so what out what up the question
I'm asking is was their level of envy
from you towards them no not at listen
see all I used the only the respect
level is this as you're getting older
you're intelligent unless you're a dummy
and you just follow blindly yeah but you
start seeing I was betrayed by them so
yeah there is I was loyal to the mob
they betrayed me there's no way you
could turn around the fact that John
Gotti Jr met with the government in 2003
or four and then he signed papers a year
later 2005 he can't change that that's a
fact
that's when he was in and that's when I
was in the penitentiary in Brazil
you can't correlate he can't so he can
try till he's dead
you can't correlate whatever I did for
what you did you did this five years
earlier so I don't know how he's even
trying to correlate whatever he did his
actions the rest of the mob knows he's
alright okay now did I come in after
that yes did Ronnie wanna cooperate no
but did he give a statement said he was
afraid I'd kill him like everybody else
of course he did
what kind of statement is that so that's
okay well the guy that comes in and he's
not the only guy Mikey scars cooperated
captain and I just said him once we
realistic you go to shore
so why am i loyal to a life of Italians
when I'm all Banyon and they're not
loyal to their own life so this is and
they given me up at the same time and
while my guys had given me up and other
guys in Who am I being loyal to because
they're not being loyal to themselves so
what do I owe them they owe me nothing
when I left my family they owed me
nothing what I stood nose penitentiaries
and it wasn't rat on my enemies I wasn't
right on anybody I left everything to be
true to that life that I believed it but
one after another made guy after a made
guy are giving me up and given
information against other made guys and
bosses I'm not just talking about just
on the links or made guys I'm talking
about who's who's gonna deny the fact
that these guys are writing like crazy
was it public when you retired in 99 or
no like did you tell them ambarita
because you said you retired in 99 99
1999 that you retired Lord in 99 I got a
jail 2000 right in 2000 I don't know if
I said I'd retired or didn't retire I
was stolen him all your stolen a mob
yeah so in 2001 when you was there
recording you heard with you and your
uncle where they said you know he's he's
not a made man he's a skip or something
like that is there is there something
with that recording your with your uncle
or no there was a recording you're
talking about Stevie Newell's incident
yes and I there was a meeting with John
Gotti junior Stevie knew it's joined
Gotti junior excuse me stayed across the
street was sending messages back and
forth to comment Agnello Pete Gotti was
involved and talking about hitting me
I shot Stevie knew the guy they supposed
to be protecting and they asked Stevie
knew can you kill Johnny a light it's
it's a joke you're asking the guy I just
shot that he's supposed to be protected
to kill me why don't you kill me you
just said you're gonna protect this guy
and I told you go [ __ ] yourself when I
shot him how did you hear about that
they wanted to put it I didn't hear
about I said that to him because the FBI
came to my house and said there was a
death threat on you we have to report it
so instead they said are you gonna tell
them and this was in about 94 but he
said are you gonna tell the guys I said
yeah yeah and I went and I and I
switched the story to them and I said I
heard a recording you guys were gonna
kill me
so at that same story I says well I just
robbed Joe Kane that you supposed to be
protected and I stabbed him a second
time his did nothing
I took Ritchie Gotti seeing his brothers
son in law I beat him to death on the
street he lived because the guy skipper
from Bonanno family saved his life the
same guy that's bringing him to me set
him up from me brought him to the
hospital Ronnie chill Enzo they did
nothing I shot my cousin that was God he
said don't pay the cop for payoff fee he
did nothing I robbed two booked
bookmakers around them they did nothing
I beat his uncle up in jail they did
nothing I beat up Ally Calabrese in
prison with other guys and these are
what they did nothing they don't do
nothing but then they went ratted on me
so you had your chance to kill me over
and over again how many things can I do
these places but when they change that
story so when when Charles came to me
and we can go on story after story and
if he's so loyal to gaudí right why is
he robbing papaver a funeral home with
me Charles goodnight why are you robbing
it with me in two thousand and whatever
year we did it one two three something
like that we robbed the funeral home of
John Gotti's main guy he was buried that
he had his funeral there I didn't give a
[ __ ] he was alive actually we robbed in
a 94 excuse me God he just went to jail
so from this guy that don't care about
thing and why is a made guy running
around with me robbing things if he
doesn't answer to me if he doesn't
respect me if he's that they don't think
I'm nothing
why are you robbing why you have no
respect for the God he's doing that with
me why you helping me give me guns to
shoot my cousin that's around Ross from
the Genovese family and he's running a
bread union with him
why why you coming given me a machine
gun in a 9-millimeter killed John Gotti
junior Pete Gotti and commenting nello
if that's not true
get the guys that testified against me
one was my cousin and knows about it and
well
Kubo cool Benelli has I put the guns in
his safe
he's a tattoo a guy in an a but he's
still around if it ain't true well
Andrew DiDonato that wrote a book about
it said Nicky carazzo told him yeah but
he didn't mention it he didn't always
mean I was gonna do it and I wouldn't
give the guns back so why why are they
so afraid of me if I'm this junkie
nobody right so this is the the point is
I ran through these guys and they never
did anything and my message is still the
same that's the past I'm a different guy
now if I wasn't I would be retaliating
against guys when they talk so much the
way I used to
now I send the message my life has
changed I'm the same guy I mean don't
get me wrong if somebody tries to hurt
me I've gotta protect myself but my
message it's a kid's day and night it's
gonna be the kids to stay away from this
life
when did you cooperate was it oh five
when you cooperate it no I cooperated
when I came back about oh seven oh seven
it was five it was oh seven yeah it was
uh
oh seven articles say 2005 no no it was
a seven Brazil penitential okay God also
operate in 2004 for 2004 I'll come back
like three or four years later and I saw
an officially about five years later
what's the story would one you went to
court to testify this one one of the
jury members Paul Paragon Perry John
however you want to pronounce I want to
hear your views from this almost the
entire jury didn't believe the star
witness yourself he wasn't credible at
all what it what is this all about
written about in different places first
of all this guy's you know we use
terminology as a mob pump so he's a mall
yeah why would you go out to dinner with
Gotti after the trial why'd you go
socialize one for that's first off
second
I can't control what all the witnesses
stay on it say on the stand
you know if somebody says something
different that they didn't hang around
us like Peter Cetera he's you know he's
a big mouth he worked with me he stayed
with me
he was gonna set up the murder of Pete
Gotti junior Gotti and carmine Agnello
but his brother was is that his brothers
a tough guy these guys used to come
visit me in prison or whatever so when
he says something at that on the stand
I can't control what he says I he never
came to our clubs actually Johnny can
accept me to hurt him too when he first
came home and what says they Privett was
that they provide owns a junkyard Bechet
stayed in the old Shea Stadium he was
there when I went pro so when these guys
are talking I can't change but here's
one of the reasons why this jury didn't
believe me because there's guys witness
after witness saying I'm too dangerous
on all the trials get the paperwork that
this guy can't control me partially they
all right he can't control me and
everything but I do work for the Gambino
family so their view is I'm lying
because no one's controlling me because
Joel Kane got on the stand saying one
thing Johnny another kid gets on the
stand saying God he never did anything a
lights crazy he baseball bat me Stevie
Newell's getting on the stand say Johnny
they chopped me Ronnie won I'm saying
I'm scared Johnny a lights gonna kill me
I'm a captain a Gambino family so what
is the jury gonna say they say this
guy's a maniac out of control since I
came home the Gotti family this is a
fact the Gotti family wrote my parole
the whole family wrote I don't know how
many letters to my parole wrote to my
paroles boss rody right judge 2013 14
yeah God he had his right to write them
and say I'm a killer and I'm gonna kill
somebody in the Gotti family they need
to lock me up you're gonna kill somebody
in the family Edie I'm gonna kill the
brother or somebody in their family they
need to lock me up I violated my parole
every gangster around the streets active
and not active still in touch with me
I'm in the drug business I'm still in
the construction business
and I'm a nobody but everybody from
every crew is getting in touch with me
so what are these letters and God
himself and his lawyers wrote a letter
in to the judge saying that he feared
for his life and his sister wrote a
letter in 1992 he doesn't have the
stomach for the mob world so but my
thing with the God exists it's not about
the guys it's about the Gambino family
the thing about correlating John Gotti
junior becoming a rat in 2004 2005 has
completely nothing to do with me while
penitentiary in Brazil I'm just curious
how they keep trying to correlate him
riding and me coming in after the fact
four three four or five years later the
correlation doesn't even make a little
sense who's behind a website who's
behind a website on Gotti junior how
certain are you abet a hard you beside
the guy Chris Kasper Rosa said he works
for John Gotti junior the guy who runs
the website as he works with John Gotti
junior this is very similar to what the
scientist I'm sorry I don't mean to cut
you off no it's okay my Google and read
my Wikipedia he controls it he locked it
he changed the the the writing of what
was on Wikipedia who did John Gotti
Joanie with Chris Kasper OSA was Elaine
even rewrite on it if you want when's
the last time you were in contact with
John Gotti junior I was in Long Island
at a diner when I first came home
thirteen thirteen I had a meeting there
were a couple guys and six police calls
came and they were for me to God he
called up and said that he had fear that
I was gonna kill me that he lives around
a corner somewhere I don't know if
that's true him or no nine and Sam and
then the letters started coming into my
parole that I left my area and I've been
in different areas in New York and I
didn't not allowed to leave New Jersey
Philadelphia area so the the thing
that's is is mind-boggling to me is the
way he won't let this go I even gave up
social media beacon four years ago
because I'm not gonna play these kid
games with him forever you know so but
the answer is still back to the same
thing how are you correlating if he
became a rat anything to do with me
would you like to face off with them not
not fight face off and have a
conversation with the would you want to
sit down I'll sit here tomorrow with you
get him on yeah when we're gonna talk
him about I will start with his father
so we don't have to talk about him we'll
talk about his father I want to know
when did he ever use a gun I want to
know when a gun was in his hand besides
that fantasy story he told in his book
that his father left Green Haven or one
of the prisons and it's two marshals
would only went to a dentist office he
went out the back door so he had about
30 people that were witnesses that he
was brought to it that so he went out
the door he did a murder that's the best
he could come to a murder for his father
it's the the kids got to know the kids
got it was his father
me strange somehow was his father a
gangsta hundred percent was he from the
screen a hundred percent did he have a
lot of guys killed a hundred percent was
he a big earner no was he degenerate
gambler yes
was he a tough guy yeah it was a street
guy he was - was he a killer with his
own hand no did he have killers around
them yes he had a ton of killers around
him
Bobby Borriello was one of John Aitken
Elia was one of them and he lino was one
of them Joe Watts was a big one Sammy
Sammy without a doubt these are guys the
most out of all of those guys Sammy and
Joe Watts without a doubt without a
doubt what out of Johnny's was tough for
him too but without a doubt at the peak
when you were on Sammy what was a
different energy you felt from Sammy
then you felt about the senior senior
even as a kid senior one in a timid
eight you right so I've got your street
he wanted you know you know and as a kid
I was intimidated I would be allowed to
say well sure you know I was
intimidating I was impressed by him but
then as you growing and you understand
the world it's like going to
kindergarten you work your way up to
college when I looked at Sammy you see
complete confidence he walked with
confidence he didn't try to stay he down
he said hello we didn't try to
intimidate you eight K and even to today
if you ask him when he met me he doesn't
know and of course he doesn't know
because I was a kid he met me at the
clubs he said he said hello but he
doesn't specifically remember
conversation cuz I'm a nobody I'm a kid
growing up and he's you know he's on the
boss so why would he pay attention it's
like guys that say they know me and I
don't remember him because I'm in a
different level you're not gonna
remember these guys he but he was always
a gentleman and as time went on yes he
seen me more and he said a lot more but
if you asked him specifically what do we
talk about he won't remember I remember
because to me it was a big deal just
like it was a big deal talking to God
he's seen you but then you learn and you
decipher hey is this guy a good leader
when you start watching people that are
good leaders through history whether
it's in law enforcement like we talked
about Rudy Giuliani right highly
intelligent guy good leader he he
Testament he did the Mafia but he made a
statement I did an interview down and
obey
about the five families and the
interviewers
very famous guy down there in the
Balkans blending said that God he's seen
you had a gun on him and I left I said
you're wrong and he says well that's
what Rudy Giuliani says all due respect
to Rudy Giuliani and I have a lot of
respect friend is he wasn't in a car but
Sammy Gravano was and there was no gun
in got a slap on hands on a jacket he
had no intention to get not at a car no
matter what he was just gonna send Sammy
out Sammy had the gun so it depends on
where this information is coming from
Phil Baroni right and I'm gonna slide
back for a second was one of the guys
who was an ex-detective that testified
in Gatti's trials and he and this is the
reason may be a problem with somebody's
juries and he said he didn't know when
we were going to kill Georgie Grasso
this is the detective that lived up the
block from me this is a detective that
when I moved to Cherry Hill New Jersey
two hours away
he moved next door to me this is the
detective that went to Mexico with me
he's my bookmaking partner with me he's
selling drugs with me he's doing armed
robberies with me but he didn't know I
was gonna shoot this guy in a head who
the [ __ ] is gonna believe that who's
stupid enough to believe that so if a
jury thinks because he's saying he
didn't know and Peter said Kara the
other guy saying I he met me in McDonald
somewhere and I said I don't even know
where as a McDonald's we met in Burger
King for a different occasion whatever
store use these guys had tell him
there's only difference between my
stories in them and his minds are truth
and I don't say I didn't kill these guys
I don't say it it shoot these guys I
don't say I ain't involved in baseball
batting these guys but when these guys
want to insult somebody and say you're
only on vacation with me Phil Baroni
couldn't get further up my ass you're a
detective that ran around with that
badge with me and we did everything
together for 20-something years you were
giving us information when Jeanne Gotti
and Johnny Koenig had a problem you get
an information that John Gotti senior
and Sammy were gonna get pinched when
they got pinched in 90 where was that
information come from was come from Phil
Baroni where did he get it from
so when these guys are talking on
Morgenthau his driver
there's returnees driver Jimmy I'm in
his house why am i able to describe your
whole house if you're not involved with
me what the [ __ ] was I doing in your
house these are the you know it did his
lawyers do a good job yeah I used a good
job he had a lawyer John Verrilli Oh
fantastic attorney every time he walked
in I said oh this guy again not because
you're lying because you know they're
gonna pick you apart they're intelligent
so when you're understanding we can't
have these conversations
of course they gotta pick you apart
there and they're going and they're
getting paperwork and I'll give you an
example I had tons of paperwork from
Brazil extradition and it was fighting
my case Marco this guy I sent them
750,000 he stole it he denied it a buddy
of mine put all the documents with the
money transfers to Brazil and he showed
he stole the money Gotti was friends
with God he had him do a video but God
he doesn't tell everybody this guy when
I was locked up facing life in the death
sentence took all my paperwork and sent
it back to United States government to
give me a life sentence my god his
behalf so when I'm on the stand they
said they got all my papers did you say
this yes is this part true no is that
part true no is that part's true no I'm
lying because back then I wasn't
cooperating so I says that's when I was
a gangster this animals gonna beat my
cases yeah I did order a murder from
Brazil where you gonna kill this guy
from Brazil that's all in a suite but
I'm trying to say yeah you could take
that paperwork some of its real
someone's fake I'm trying to save my
life
now I'm honest and testify against the
guy who I called Whitey Bulger you gave
me up would you think was I fool I was
gonna say I'm gonna go to jail and do
ten life sentences for a guy that had my
best friend from college
Timmy Donovan testify against me cuz you
said to so he did and he testified for
you when you have the Accardi brothers
the famous Crawford County family John
and Jason and the father testified
against me because gaudí said they could
or you have Robert lamendola testify
against me because God he said he could
well Joel can't give fake information
understand because he said so or Johnny
the car thief that I baseball bat it cuz
John Gotti said so I could go through
someone
seems that he told everybody testify
against me they couldn't kill me so this
was the way they were gonna kill me he
was right on me so when I came back and
I got all the paperwork and I found out
everybody's testifying against and
giving me up then yes I did come in and
I never hid the fact I'm not like
everybody else I said you'd think that
betrayed me I didn't betray anybody so
when I came in it was years after John
was in it was years after Mikey scars
was it it was years and Captain it was
years and if at daum was given given
people it was a made guy these are all
Gotti's guys they were all talking I'm
not talking I left my family I left my
money
I went penniless I lived in Cuba I lived
in Colombia I lived in Africa not to rat
so when these guys switching this dates
can't lie paperwork can't lie the only
difference is I've always been a man I
stand on my two feet so when I came in I
come in and I don't hide the fact he's
betrayed me I owe you nothing
it's interesting listening to these
stories you know for me I've interviewed
a few CIA agents one of the one we
interviewed she was the chief disguise
officer of the US government so she
would disguise faces and she went to
Bush one time she disguised the face
Bush can recognize and she took the mask
off saying how great of a disguise this
was she married another CIA agent
because they met each other in the
business I said let me ask you a
question how do you how do you believe
each other she says it's a very good
question I said because both of you are
trained to lie for good reason right
because you lie to protect your
countries so if you sit down with a
Russian operative you're not gonna tell
every story you're gonna lie as much as
you can right so so how does one when
when sitting and you hear all these
stories somebody who's not in the world
you'll just listen to the stories you
hear so many different sides and
everybody sounds convincing well you
have to take like I just said you have
to take Ronnie 1 on his opening
statement why did he say that why do you
say he fears I'm gonna kill him you're a
captain why would the guy I shoot say he
see ya guys from the Gambino family
skipper's answered
why would you have the underboss of the
Gambino family say he was our hit man
for the Gambino family specifically for
the Gottis he was there strong why would
you have my key scars the skipper John
Gotti joined his best friend right hand
men say I'm there during these
conversations why would I be in Gatti's
wedding why am I on a list given him
five thousand at the Helmsley Palace was
only a handful of gangsters around the
world there why am I in sisters what a
me this is very simple it's not my word
why am i saying he's a rat I have the
paperwork I come in years later after
they already [ __ ] me so this is not
this is steppin it's not my my word this
is step by step when I was on the stand
I couldn't show pictures of Phil Baroni
because they were in my house the
detective that claimed all this nonsense
so explain to me who is it what do you
think the odds are a billion to one five
billion to one that this detectives
selling drugs with me robbing with me
bookmaking with me moves next door to me
in Cherry Hill all the real estate in
the world you came to Cherry Hill to sit
next to me what are you doing at my
house every day how many pictures you
want cuz after this week I could give
you pictures what is Carmine Agnello
right never shot a gun in his life 16
count indictment disappears in the
courtroom closes do we have to be
geniuses to understand what he did so
you know I'm not asking anybody to
believe what I'm saying just look at the
facts why these guys talk alike yeah who
do you trust today do you do are you
easy to trust people today or after a
life like this I mean you're you're 57
years old how do you trust anybody today
you know do you see people and you say I
think you're 56 to be exact September 30
years your birthday yes so who do you
trust yourself today listen you don't
live there like you said treacherous
life so who do you travel guys like you
legitimate guys that have no agendas
that'll respectful purely agenda and
friends like my friends as friends of
mine that I grew up since were kids that
are attorneys court stenographers with
five years old my friend my friend
Michael Jacobs I know him since he's
five years old these guys have no
agendas but friendship they're not
weasels with money they're not calling
somebody trying to set me up from behind
my back they're not guys that are dying
to make their name themselves off me and
you got
that I'll call up and I'll give you an
example a guy calls me out of nowhere
fake number and he tells me he's part of
a crew Albanians I don't talk against
Albanians I try not to kill veins at
hurdle beans in my life and he claims
he's involved in a crew well Baines that
went to jail and he said some choice
words for me so I told him you know why
I says I'm gonna give you 15 seconds
this is what I'm gonna do feel I said
first if you all who you are I know
you're a dog Isis because while your
friends are on prison what are you doing
home it's a second if they had no
evidence against you when all your
friends got went to prison because they
challenged the Gambino family why didn't
you go kill anybody for them I said yeah
you're talking like a killer but you're
not a killer because you're not in jail
with them you didn't get revenge for
them and any of those guys on that case
as much as I don't want to disrespect
them they didn't kill anybody so one of
these guys get off talking or even
questioning me well my life when they
have no knowledge of it so I have no
business questioning your life or
disrespecting you in any which way
unless I was involved with you or unless
I told you I used the name earlier Vito
ghazal because like him or leave him
like or disagree with his cruel crimes
and they try to kill me and in reports
all the guys that cooperated said they
try to kill me ten times so they have
the right to talk about me because we
were in throwing back and forth trying
to kill each other shoot each other
robbing each other so they do have the
right even if I disagree
I personally give them the respect
either way if I like this but I respect
them there's a difference like in sports
like anything but when guys are talking
out of school that don't even understand
this life and they get on a chat and
they want to feel important with
especially when guys reach out to me and
talk they're only talking because this
is a night this isn't 1985 or 86 or 87
or 90 or pro/5 we all of course okay so
the biggest mistake anybody ever made in
life is when they challenge and threaten
somebody because that's usually when you
talk to a serious guy that you can have
an issue now with me I don't take them
serious because if they were if they
this energy there's a lot of guys out
there there don't like me right a lot of
guys out they want to kill me
but they're not on the internet talking
about it those are the guys I got to
worry about not these idiots ought to be
trying to get attention sure so you got
a guy like Johnny Burke I'm gonna use
him he's got a life sentence this is a
guy that was around the Rosie onyl
family it was a drug addict got baseball
bounded by carmine and John Gotti Jr did
nothing about it this is a guy to let
his family sit in the street with no
money didn't buy him a house I had to
give him 60,000 to buy a house this is a
guy that left
Citrus County Jail twice to go meet with
the prosecutors he didn't go to Disney
World and try to make a deal this is a
guy whose mother threatened us in 2001
if we didn't give him money he was gonna
rat this is a guy that got run over by
Brendan Cabot and did nothing about it
said a hospital and he came running it
to me can you help me this is a guy that
was with me on the robbery in Valley
Stream when I robbed Joe Joe carazzo and
Ronnie wants bookmaker that refused to
come he was scared this is a guy whose
brother married a police officer but
calls everybody a rat this is a guy who
they did the whole house of an FBI agent
for free and when his brother were
meeting with him but he calls everybody
or at this is a guy who teaches his kids
to talk just like him and this is the
problem why I keep doing these shows for
kids because don't follow these guys
they're full of [ __ ] they ain't about
nothing and this is a guy that Maddy I
won't say his last name shot him in the
throat because he talked too much Johnny
Burke this is a guy in jail that was
getting shaken down and it's Citrus
County when he came to the jail I was at
I got him in a sally port and I told him
I know your rat he cried this is the
same guy that's talking on internet sand
and because they can Google they can use
the internet now from prison this is a
guy that if I told him to do anything I
wanted he would've did it and said
please can I do it again so when they
able to talk on internet sand computers
because it's a different world but no
one's talking about this and his family
doesn't know all this stuff but his
mother knows that you and I made guys
that are cooperating Patsy adriano Dave
del pino Peter said Carol made every one
of them before all these cases come go
pay his mother before he snitches any
right sauce and this is a guy in 1994
got out of trouble for a state case and
I gotta
that we will question how he got out and
I can go on you know with more stories
about them so when these guys talk the
problem is their mouths not just you
know they're not so shut you can't stop
them from talking so they want to change
the storyline what happened this is the
first guy that rolled out all these guys
so when his sister or somebody's talking
I don't even blame them because they're
hearing it from him when we got EES kids
are talking cuz I tell my kids shut your
mouth - mind your business about my life
using regular kids if any gangster wants
to be a gangster still with me
I'm very accessible I don't leave New
York so if you still think you're that
killer then you're allowed to take a
shot jump like we used to stand Street
right you froggy take a jump leap so
were you talking about kids for I don't
want to talk about anybody's kids so you
know I make this very easy for anybody
it still says the gangsters just what
you said it's over but if they wanted to
be a gangster go ahead you know what
you're gonna end up you're gonna life if
that's you're trying to get a name off
yourself we're talking about different
life today like fear and structure was
the key and those two things when you
lose those two things it's tough too
tough to control so you know the whole
part you said something you said uh I'm
trying to change my life but you also
don't believe certain things change
about a person right like you comment
something about change you've lived this
life for a while how do you I know you
said something you had a hard time going
to sleep at nights you're still having a
scene therapist sometimes talking to
some people you know to kind of be able
to flush it out it's not like you only
did it for a year two years three years
you you live this life for some time how
are you I opted to stay changed because
I was diagnosed with PTSD I don't hide
that fact was I try to help soldiers and
all the people have been diagnosed with
it I don't hide the fact that I see a
therapist I don't hide the fact I'm like
an alcoholic I said it over and over
again it's easy for me to hurt somebody
who kill someone that's an easy part for
me it's easy I don't say anything
different the hard part is not doing it
when they talk crazy and talk stupidness
so you have to work at things right so I
get through it date each day so today I
got through today I worry about tomorrow
tomorrow but I'm not gonna change who I
am so Who I am
this I don't need to call 10 guys and
the reason why I said when I baseball
batted this guy and I say who's there
and by myself when I shot these guys I'm
by myself because I want people to
understand
I don't need 20 guys to feel strong and
I didn't need a hundred guys to say I'm
cooperating now because they betrayed me
I just ran through this the mob betrayed
me I didn't betray them so not gonna
switch that on me
I'm not one of these dumb guys I was
educated college educated street
educated I'm college educated yeah I
went to college also so I think graduate
the four years but I went to college
three years so I'm educated I understand
life right and I understand if John
Gotti junior ever turned around and
learned to be a gentleman shook my hand
and said let's forget about the past
because there's a ton of guys out there
that tried to kill me that I'm friends
with now the guy Stevie knew that he
planned on killing me and I shot him
what friends because there's a level of
respect again I'm going to go back to
level respect but when you want to
[ __ ] the public and yourself and
throw your garbage on me and you're not
man enough to say this is what I did
I'll never be your friend I'll never
respect you so when you turn around and
you be a gentleman and say okay this is
what happened I couldn't take the life
anymore yeah I did cooperate I'm good
with it I don't care I'm not gonna hold
nothing against you because I moved on
there's guys that robbed my money big
big money like that kidding
Marco 750,000 I don't go looking to kill
him you still miss the lights do you
still miss any of it anybody it says
they don't miss the life at my opinion
it's been in their life like we are is
Alaia I think we all missed a life but
the only difference is we get older we
get smarter we understand there is no
loyalty and I think you miss like we all
say camaraderie and all that and I joke
about I said well join a bowling team so
if you missed a camaraderie but I know
that this life of what I thought it was
as a young man as a kid does not exist
so you know my friends that I when I am
together what my friends are the guys I
grew up with and we go to the beach or
we go as families I don't miss the mob
when I'm with them because again now you
with real friends and you don't got to
look over your shoulder and I don't got
to worry about getting in a car and I
don't got to worry about anything with
them and that you know there's no
treachery his only true French
and love for each other than our
families and this is the part the kids
really got to understand because I know
I was there I know that it's enticing
right and all this is enticing but just
what you said I'll be allow you to tell
you you know Ralph allah tala from
philly said i sleep like a baby and do I
like Ralph either all right guy but I
said he's full of [ __ ]
because I don't I think if you talk to
anybody's been in the Armed Forces seen
action or anybody from the streets or a
police officer that did shootings you're
not sleeping you're a lion it's just not
possible you just you know because
subconsciously it is guilt and you know
you ask me it seems like I don't care
earlier I do care that's why I go to
therapy all the time I did get in touch
with so you just for information you in
the public I got in touch with tons of
my victims some would talk to me some
wouldn't I cried with some and somebody
didn't but this show is not about how I
feel this is not about my personality of
you know regret nobody wants to hear
that because and at that point doesn't
mean anything if they do it don't it
does to me of the families I need to
speak to independent the families I need
to apologize or the families but again
and I'll be a lawyer if I see anything
different I'm still the same guy so that
means if somebody busted in this room
right now and try to hurt us you're
still capable of course there'll be a
life I said well what's the story that
Jake you did on your GQ magazine did a
story on you what was it about
GQ talk to me about I did a Netflix
series and this was just a month ago
just yeah I did a Netflix thing that's
coming out and you spoke to me about
that it's about five families and this
is also about is five families with the
author the the the the same guy that
wrote the book five families no okay got
it and it's just the yeah yeah I mean
there's a notebook out now actually
Gatti's boys with the Tony DeStefano
actually you know I talked to him and I
skimmed through the book I've been right
at all and it's pretty good book so you
know it's a different perspective he
speaks about me and some of the pretty
accurate there's some accurate what I
read is some of its accurate someone
does not you know I called him on one of
them and it's a you know he was talking
about Mark Ryder and I was you know
somebody said because of my age you know
he doesn't believe I was wearing and I
said to him you know what's funny I said
and I said
listen you're never gonna get a book
completely factual Isis mock right I
took him on a run what do you want it's
a Disney World I took him when he went
to California I took him with a woman
Rose Marie Fanelli
and we helped him get apartments and he
went all the places so when they talk
they don't really have the facts and you
know I love that family and I feel
terrible for whatever happened to his
life and he lost his son and his son was
a great friend of mine and you know they
never found the body
and you get guys like my other friend
and this is the treachery they life
Keith Pellegrino since he's a kid he was
one of my drug partners I know my god
him guys wanted to hurt him I saved him
the same guy that stayed with us knew
about Greg's murder and never told us
and hid it from us and was involved with
one of the guys who was involved in
murder that's the treachery of the life
and he's not a tough guy Keith he
actually he was a punk you know so if it
wasn't for me protecting him he would
end up dead so how do you do that to one
of our friends right so this is why I'm
saying the kids get away from this life
go play baseball go to school go become
a lawyer go become a truck driver do
something legitimately do what you're
doing journalism but don't end up on the
street because there is no true
friendships there and and and I would
say you know a lot of times people ask
me they say why do you what do you
interview people in this world and I
said you know first of all I did the
interview community the mobster
community came purely accidental
obviously I grew up with a lot of the
history of its study in it you know the
whole Godfather's you know it's a very
if you ask any CEO entrepreneur a lot of
people will say one of the most powerful
movies you can wash you learn about
business The Godfather wanted to maybe
not three but you can learn a lot of our
business and it gives different
perspectives on what you can do with
business but but if there's one thing
about it is hearing all these different
stories and knowing there's always a
power play to be done and if you are too
naive like you said earlier and you're
not antis anticipating next move and
making notes of certain people's
behavior in some strange moments it
could catch up to you that could happen
in business just like it is in your
world the differences in your world you
could get killed in a business world you
put out a business well
I talked early about this kid Frankie I
heard right we'll use an example I like
the guy it was nothing personal the the
Johnny Canoga and John Jeanie at the
time asked me to hurt him over the drug
business but the thing is I like them I
respect him he and he was legitimately a
tough kid he's a big kid
six-five would have his friends tough
guys left them left them and they didn't
retaliate with him afterwards and they
didn't try to him now they're talking
these same guys had the opportunity and
this is why I'm telling kids not even
just one end the other guys I even hurt
well guys you know I respect you I'm
trying to say even the guys like that
look what's going on on to them where's
their friends when they needed them
there was a made guy at the time Jerry
Sarah was with him standing what I mean
I don't get lost or I'll hurt you too
and he walked his father just got a done
basically life sentence for me Sarah
they accused him of the environment
would deal with dozens of stuff and so
but his son so and his on the front
Frankie now is an enabled what a big
mouth where were you when he needed you
where were you coming now 30 years later
when we're all retired where were you
when we were all loading guns and I say
that forget about shooting the gun these
guys never loaded the gun Louis it was a
water pistol so I'm trying to say the
same thing over and over and over again
right much as I can
these kids need to understand stay away
from this life because they don't they
think just like I did as a kid and it's
very hot prestige you know the whole
thing you know the movie Goodfellas and
you go out and the ladies and you know
the cars and all that stuff what's your
part of it is true I mean when I talk to
a lot of these guys listen you guys have
partied hard you guys have had a lot of
fun own the hottest nightclubs around I
had everything but I'm going to tell you
when I sat in that cell alone it was all
over every one of my friends in that
life started ratting on me
all of them like 50 guys 50 something I
usually they all went to the grand
juries on me you can check with Florida
prosecute Middle District of Florida and
asking because when these conversations
started I think was 54 was the number
actually that ratted on me all these mob
made guys ratting on me when all the
money was gone so it was all the woman
sure so was all everybody else and so
was my even my other friends that were
the street that weren't killers but they
were you know playing around on street
with drugs and there was nobody near me
I was alone in a Cell and I'm gonna tell
you like I tell everybody cuz if you're
gonna be fake
you can't talk to kids and you're
sitting in that cell and you're crying
and I like when somebody said did you
cry yeah I'm a man I'm not a robot of
course I cried and I said well you did
this you did that I'm not asking anybody
feel bad for me I said that's not why
I'm saying it I'm saying it to kids so
they understand right that this ain't
all about that and when your kids aren't
seeing you and I didn't see some of my
cry for kids I didn't see two of them
for 10 years you know so I just
agreement with the mom and I'm a mom and
I'm friends would have now is a very
conciliation she's remarried but this is
the reality of the life that the kids
got understand and when my uncle died he
was like my father I lived with him in
California I didn't see him I never get
to say goodbye to him and you know
you're sitting in that cell and you're
crying you're right
and this times when you're crying so no
one is saying to me well poor you well
[ __ ] you you know because I know people
on this sure and I'm not asking anybody
say father poor me
I'm not asking anybody this is my life I
stood on my two feet and I gotta accept
everything but the reality of a kid that
wants to go on the street is I need to
tell you you're gonna cry and if you say
you're not I know
tough guys kill us I mean killers ain't
never getting out of jail and I got a
ton of friends that are on the street
still in jail and and off the streets so
people say well I seen him with this guy
I don't like say I don't know them
anymore a lot of them are my friends
still I just ain't involved with them
anymore
I'll have lunch with him around the
world I'm talking about gangsters in and
out of jails I got a ton of friends in
jails I got fan guys that could write me
on a constant basis I said I shouldn't
use the word fan Isis cuz I respect them
for writing me from jail and they tell
me we wish we could be man and I'll do
what you're doing and I said took me a
long time to be a man like this it's
easy doing the other stuff I'll say it
over again easy to shoot and kill this
is the hard part to admit all this stuff
and try to get convinced some kids if
you could save one or two this is
terrible time to want to live that life
because you got 300 million cameras
everywhere you got 300 million cameras
everybody's going live everything is
recorded everybody's walking on with a
record so terrible time to do it but
watch the news right and I'm not even
talking about gangsters
criminals doing dump [ __ ] and they
notice a camera then they still do it
and then almost saying cheese on the
camera now walking that's what I'm
saying to you they did obviously there's
a lot of fools but one of the great
equalizers I believe of getting people
to not want to go in that direction of a
life is social media I think that's
that's done the social media and
smartphones have change again John what
book are you currently working on that
we can share with our audience if there
was one book we could share which one
would it well it's this is Susan Pike
with me is a called darkest hour there's
gonna be serious talks out two and three
okay this was a set up book after
Gotti's rules because I did got his
rules with Georgia Anastasia and the set
up book we don't really talk about my
childhood this is a set up book for two
and three and two and three I'm gonna
really get into all these things I'm
talking about shootings I'm gonna get
into more but this book different than
the first Gotti's Rules is I'm gonna
list just like I did names I just did
know and I'm gonna make sure that
there's gonna be people that were there
witnesses from somebody wants to contact
see the truthfulness contact and then
I'm gonna do a scorecard of every
gangster I mentioned in that book how
many armed robberies they did how many
actual shootings they did themselves a
community are you gonna piss off a lot
of people if they're alive you're gonna
piss off a lot of those well it's going
to be interesting for them to come back
and say that's not true I did this you
had this many say if I say carmine
Agnello I'm gonna use him because he had
a big mouth right he is right the
brother-in-law yeah and he ran to
Cleveland and his courtroom got shut
down in a 16 count indictment that does
not go away and I guess somebody could
talk to Julian Eric to the sister yeah
yeah his life so was all the son get
balls up and get it gonna come looking
for me
so you know to me I'm just gonna bring
out let these guys and if you want to do
the right thing maybe you should talk to
your kids and tell them the same thing
and other kids let's not follow this
life because I got nothing against any
of their kids I you know I hope that
kids don't ever follow us and I hope my
kids do the same and I've had problems
with one of my sons so you know the
reality is break the cycle
rice is a terrible time to want to go
down life
terrible time to want to go that route
John again thank you for flying out to
Dallas to do this sit down we're gonna
put the links to both of the books as
well as the GQ article and if you want
to find out more about his books or the
article go to the link below we're gonna
put every single one of the links on how
to find out more about John a lights
book both the gaudy rules as well as the
darkest hour once again thanks for
coming out thank you too pal yeah
preciate you
you